I I did a big analysis of chat GPT and I
I was pretty surprised that that um you
know when when chat GPT first came out I
I know that the people who made it and I
said did you know it was going to work
and they said no it's um and I you know
none of us knew it was going to work if
you looked at its predecessors they
didn't work well and and suddenly chat
gbt started working and I I even wrote
um I wrote a little piece about about
how it works and it even exists now as a
book and I just saw this today for the
first time but um let me let me show you
wonder if I have some pictures here well
you know the basic strategy of of you
know what chat GPT is doing is it's
taking uh sort of everything a bunch of
a trillion words basically from the web
from a bunch of books things like that
and it's saying given that I was started
with this the the words the best thing
about AI is its ability to given what I
saw on the web what's the next word
likely to be that's it that's its basic
strategy and it just keeps doing that
word by word and it's kind of remark
able um nowadays these things have well
it used to be 4,000 it's now more than
that uh window of words that it pays
attention to it's generating one word at
a time but yet it manages to maintain
sort of coherence um by having a large
window of of words that it can look back
to okay so the question is so you can
kind of go and see um got some nice
pictures perhaps that's rather
uninteresting that's just how neural
Nets get trained um but you can kind of
look inside oh there there's a piece of
the brain of chat GPT it's kind of fun
that's sort of an encoding of a mixture
of human knowledge and human language
somewhere deep inside um uh inside the
gpt3 I think in this case um the
question is so one question is what is
this doing why does it work one thing to
realize about it is that it is
ultimately a neural net where everything
just flows through from the beginning to
the end once you've trained a chat GPT
um it is you're feeding it the words the
feed reading it words so far and it is
just Rippling through this big neuron
net that happens to have 175 billion
weights in this particular case um and
telling you what the probabilities for
the next word should be so it's doing in
a sense a very shallow computation it's
doing I think it's a um a few hundred
layers deep um and but it's just like
given a word it's going to Ripple
through and figure out probabilities for
next words um and uh the um uh and the
thing to realize that it's not doing is
that irreducible computation that I
talked about it's just Rippling through
and saying what's the next word going to
be and it it the only way that it gets
to do a non-trivial computation it can
actually do Universal computation in
principle is by looking you kind of get
to see all the steps that it shows
because every word every time it
generates a new word it looks at all the
words it's generated before and that's
its only way of kind of having a
recursive uh process of doing things but
in any case as as um the thing that it
ends up being a rather shallow
computation um relative to the kinds of
things that we see in typical
irreducible computations even in very
cases of very simple program so there's
a difference between what we see for
example in nature where we see many
irreducible computations happen that go
for a long way and what we see in
something like chat GPT and the thing to
to realize if we ask why does chat gbt
actually work I think the answer is that
it's something that Aristotle might have
got to but didn't quite get there and
it's the following thing so people sort
of find it remarkable that chat gbd can
do logic well how did Aristotle come up
with logic well he looked at a bunch of
I mean we don't know really but sort of
a model for it would be looked at a
bunch of examples of rhetoric a bunch of
arguments that people have made and said
oh there are these patterns in the
arguments people made those patterns are
syllogistic logic those are these
particular forms of syllogism that where
one thing is to do from another and
that's what chat GPT is seeing in in
lots of the texts that it finds on the
web it's seeing essentially syllogisms
um because it sees when you get this and
this and this it gives this um and so
the uh uh so it sort of discovers
soloistic logic but it discovers more
than syllogistic logic it discovers in a
sense what one might call a semantic
grammar of language I think so in
language we're used to the idea that
there is a syntactic grammar a grammar
where for example we know that nouns and
verbs go together in certain ways we
know different parts of speech match up
in certain ways but we don't have a
similar kind of thing that goes at a
more semantic level of asking what are
the ways in which uh you know what how
do you put together words in ways that
make make some
sense making sense is different from
actually being realized in the world but
at least make sense so to speak and you
know there were lots of experiments that
were done in the 1600s actually on
So-Cal philosophic iCal languages some
more recent work that's been done I've
long been interested in the question of
whether one I mean in a sense our W from
language computational language is for a
large number of domains a language that
gives you this kind of semantic grammar
a language that allows you to specify
meaningful things about lots of kinds of
domains doesn't cover all domains it
doesn't cover a lot of domains of of
typical everyday human discourse it
covers domains that are relevant for for
understanding things like the natural
world but any case that that um U that's
the
um uh the the the kind of I think the
reason that chat can work is that we
humans are making use of some
essentially a semantic grammar that is
in a sense a a a further version of
logic um that uh uh that it's managed to
piece together so to speak and there's
probably a much more efficient way of
doing what it does by just directly
using that kind of symbolic semantic uh
grammar but any case by by the way a
thing that um uh We've um uh I wrote
something about and maybe you'll see
some more about in in due coures is once
you have something like chat jpt that is
dealing with human language it becomes
kind of a a way of of being a linguistic
interface to things in the world so you
might just have a set of bullet points
about oh I want to say this and this and
this okay you tell it make make a whole
essay about that and and it can do that
but you know what it's doing is is
constructing text that is kind of you
know text that is kind of like what you
would expect it to be based on the text
that it read from the web it can't do
these sort of irreducible computations
but if it could use tools like we humans
use tools then it could do those things
if for example it could call wolf from
alpha which conveniently happens to have
a natural language interface then it
would be able to ask things and actually
do those computations so maybe something
you can you can find something I wrote
about this in January and maybe maybe
more will happen along those lines in
the rather near future but I'll I'll
I'll just mention one thing maybe which
is kind of thinking about what is the
world like when the world is run by
AIS and what what is that what does it
feel like to be in a world that's that's
run by AIS so you know much of what the
AIS do is things which will not be
comprehensible to us and we can expect
so in a sense there's all this
computation going on and it's
computation that we
can we we essentially the point is that
once we have a situation where kind of
the the there are AIS everywhere so to
speak it is very similar to the
situation that we already have with
nature nature is already running all
these computations We Exist around
nature so to speak and the we we have
found ways to uh and there's there's
also more to say about this kind of
Observer Theory business and how that
relates to the way we perceive nature
and the way we perceive kind of the
civilization of of the AIS but I suppose
the the um the thing that perhaps is a
is a useful place to end perhaps is is
uh it's the beginning of the thing I
wrote yesterday but but anyway is this
is this idea that um uh you know when
when the world is full of AI computation
it is in a sense nothing new because the
world is already full of computation in
nature and the question of then how we
interact with those AIS that happen to
be things that we constructed is a
different question that I tried to
address a bit in the thing I wrote
yesterday all right I should stop there
thanks if you enjoyed that clip then the
full podcast is out right now you can
click around here enjoy subscribe to
theories of everything to get notified
of upcoming podcasts as there are new
fulllength podcasts every week on the
topics of mathematics physics
Consciousness free will in
AI